one of the biggest fears that I struggle
with is the fear of missing out is there
a better opportunity are there other
people I should be talking to is this
the right place to eat or visit the fear
of missing out looms large in my life
today we'll explore fomo and how to deal
with it I'm Matt Abrahams I teach
strategic communication at Stanford
Graduate School of Business welcome to
think fast talk smart the POS
[Music]
today I am really excited to speak with
Patrick mcginness Patrick is the
bestselling author of fear of missing
out practical decision-making in a world
of overwhelming choice and the 10%
entrepreneur he is also the Creator and
host of the fomos sapiens podcast
Patrick thanks so much for being here
thanks so much for having me I certainly
don't want to miss out of any of our
conversations so let's go ahead and get
started it's hard for me to to believe
but I'm actually talking to the
originator of the term fomo fear of
missing out in preparing for this chat
you told me that fomo in your words
hijacks us and takes us away from our
intentions and gets us to do and say
things we don't want and probably
shouldn't want I'd love for you to share
more about what fomo is and how does it
work against us yeah fomo is it's a word
that we use in jest a lot it's sort of
like a mean and and it is a word that I
created when I wrote about it in a humor
article in the newspaper of Harvard
Business School about 20 years ago when
I was a student there so sorry Stanford
people fomo was invented at Harvard and
it would have probably stayed there
except that all my classmates all go to
McKenzie all over the world and started
using it and then there was a guy who
was my neighbor his name is Mark
Zuckerberg who happened to start this
company called Facebook that gave us all
fomo when I invented it I saw it very
much as a high class problem of MBA
students who had so many options they
could go anywhere they wanted on the
weekend they could fly off to Europe
they could go on vacation they could
apply to a million jobs all that sort of
stuff now what that has materialized
into today is a phenomenon in which many
of us because of the pernicious effects
of social media because of the
accelerant that is being able to figure
out what other people are doing all the
time we are living lives in which we are
constantly comparing ourselves to other
people we are seeing the that are out
there and then we were saying what I'm
doing right now isn't good enough I am
missing out on something and so it's not
just about the party or the vacation it
goes much much deeper when I go on
LinkedIn I start to question every
decision I've ever made professionally
when I see my classmates or the CEO of
this or the partner at that and it the
reality is of course that all of this is
an internal struggle it is something we
are putting on ourselves we are creating
a narrative inside of our head about
something that we don't even really know
that much about we don't know if we'd
like to be a partner at a law firm or a
a partner at Goldman saxs we don't know
if we would like to go to this place or
do that thing but we create a best case
scenario just like we put filters on
social media and then we compare our
present condition to those things and we
feel inadequate so that's the hijacking
that happens I certainly personally
myself have suffered from a lot of fomo
it's been something that I've struggled
with for a long time and when I learned
of the term it actually gave me some
Solace because it helped me realize that
I wasn't the only one I mean if there's
a term out there and people are talking
about it then it actually helped to put
into perspective for me however I still
struggle with it so I'm wondering if you
can suggest ways to reduce or stop fomo
and I'm especially curious if you can
give ideas or suggest ways in which
communication plays a role in how we can
reduce our fomo
I love this problem and part of the
reason I love this problem is because
the
communication that we're focusing on is
internal it is the internal talk track
of your life and as somebody who has
always been highly competitive and loved
to
win my talk track has constantly been
I'm not good enough I'm not doing the
best thing and that is so many of us in
the world of mbas and business people
and all the things that we all do and
it's a motivator so like fomo is not all
bad fomo is a beautiful motivator and if
we can tap into it and control it and
not let it get out of hand it can be
wonderful but the problem is if it gets
out of hand it causes us to do bad
things it causes us to feel bad it has a
lot of emotional tools there's a real
psychological sort of implication here
now how then do we manage that internal
conversation well fomo is created by two
powerful forces the first is what I call
the aspirational fomo it's the idea that
some bigger and better shinier and that
we want to have that thing right it's
great in a sense because it means that
we want more and we have aspirations but
of course what happens is that it gets
out of hand so the aspirational fomo is
part one the second is herd fomo
everybody's doing that thing I not
should I be doing that thing and that
comes from our earliest humans I mean
our ancestors they stuck together in
packs because if they got separated they
didn't have the information they didn't
have the physical safety they needed of
course today it's not physical safety
it's psychological safety that we're
seeking when we have foma so to deal
with those we must attack each one for
the aspirational foma we must ask
ourselves it's a pretty basic set of
questions things like is that thing as
good as it looks can I afford to do that
do I have time to do that what are the
tradeoffs I must make to do that and
then we must dig into that thing and
replace the fear with facts so that we
can make a decision based on data not
emotion so that's how you attack the
aspirational fomo on the herd fomo
that's a question of motivation and so
the question you must ask yourself is
why why do I want this thing is this
something I truly want do I have agency
or am I simply following the crowd and
we all know from we were little kids
that you don't just follow the crowd
nobody you know if so and so jumps off a
bridge will you jump off of course not
yet emotionally and psychologically when
we have fomo we're jumping off many
bridges so you got to attack those two
roots and then you were good to go thank
you for delineating the inner workings
of fomo the the aspirational versus The
Herd makes a lot of sense to me I had
never thought of that but in reflecting
on the fomo I have I certainly have both
but it helps to have names to those and
the ability to introspect to reflect as
a way to help ourselves out of it and to
change that talk track makes a lot of
sense to me I love your fear to fact
combat the fear by looking at the facts
and then really questioning our
motivations makes a lot of sense so
thank you for that you've also coined
another term phobo fear of a better
option can you help us understand what
is phobo and how is it different from
fomo it is a very very high class
problem fobo stands for fear of a better
option it's the idea that we are waiting
for something slightly better to come
along you know you're trying to pick the
hotel for the vacation you've got three
job offers you're on the dating app and
you keep swiping and swiping and swiping
and you never actually choose and unlike
fomo I like to think of sort of this is
like drinking wine and smoking fomo is
like drinking wine you know you can
drink some wine and if you have a lot of
wine of course it's bad but you have a
little wine it's okay you have a little
more fun you loosen up you dance all
that sort of stuff Phobos like smoking
nothing good about phobo and also
terrible secondhand effects so it is the
kind of thing that I see amongst my
friends and classmates from Harvard
Business School the more
options you have the more money the more
power you become trapped within this
world of fobo because you can because
it's really an Affliction of affluence I
love how you used a really powerful
analogy of helping clarify through the
analogy of drinking versus smoking I
always look for how people explicate
Concepts and you did a great job there I
too I guess I'm fortunate enough to have
phobo I guess it's a gift right that you
can actually experience it so let me ask
you the same question I asked regarding
fomo what can we do to help reduce or
stop phobo from in some ways paralyzing
us and making us miserable when we
should actually be doing quite well yeah
and it's close to fomo there are very
similar characteristics here but again
it's that internal talk track and saying
to yourself oh if I just keep looking if
I keep searching I will find something
better and that is fellacio because what
happens is that we fool ourselves into
thinking that the more we look the
better we will come out but the reality
is the longer you wait the more likely
it is that in fact some of those options
slip away and that is the danger over
time options they don't last forever
right they do go away and so number one
is to remember that and number two is to
have a conversation with yourself about
what really matters what am I actually
looking for what are my criteria a lot
of times people get stuck because
they've never set the criteria that
they're trying to measure towards and so
if you do create that criteria you're
positioned to be able to then make
better decisions now what I do and this
is where things get extra fun and I did
a fun video for Ted around this that was
called how to make faster decisions is
that a lot of the things that give me
phobo actually are things that don't
really matter it's like which restaurant
to go to or which hotel or which TV to
buy stuff like that because why because
when you go on Amazon and you want to
buy a pair of white socks there are a
thousand different choices it's
overwhelming we live in a world where
there's just too much I Outsource
everything I never picked the restaurant
you pick the restaurant I don't decide
the TV I get the wire cutter on New York
Times to do it for me I just go with
what they say and so the more that you
do that you Outsource simple decision-
making in your life you actually build
up a muscle around decision- making in
fobo that is very powerful so two things
I heard there first you need to think
about what does success look like what
is it that I'm really trying to achieve
here have some goals around that to then
help become criteria for decision making
and then when
possible don't put yourself in a
position where you have to be concerned
about what a potential outcome could be
Outsource it if you can I love that idea
I can't tell you in my immediate family
there's a lot of rumination over
decisions that I think could be easily
outsourced to people who are better
served to make those decisions like wire
cutter like Consumer Reports things of
that nature in a conversation you and I
had in advance of this Patrick you
shared with me that you love language
and love words and I just want to
comment on that it comes through in your
communication I love that you use words
like fallacious and percious and use
analogies to help explain things you're
an author a podcast host you're using
language all the time talk to me about
your thoughts on language and the
importance of it and why is it important
what do you think about when you think
about using language effectively that's
the best question anybody's ever asked
me in all of my interviews ever and I
mean that I love that just put a smile
on my face because I do love language
and I also speak four languages so I
speak Spanish Portuguese and French and
I love foreign language as well and I
love the English language to me when
you're using
words it's it's just like a puzzle that
you're building spontaneously and why
not try to make it as interesting as
possible and and so to me it's just like
a a constant opportunity to amuse myself
and to challenge myself to be clever and
that's why I so enjoy meeting people who
love words as well and who are clever
conversationalists because it's sort of
like a game you're playing a game that
is very fast-paced and fun and the
reality is if you use language
creatively you'll never be bored and I
am easily bored so that's really that's
really what it is for me I appreciate
that I too see communication as a puzzle
and I love trying to play with
communication I'm a huge fan of
alliteration and I always try to throw
alliteration in wherever I can what I
find that you do really interesting and
I'd love for people to listen to how you
speak you will use engaging words and
vocabulary that might not be as common
but you then very quickly in either the
example you give or the very next phrase
you in essence Define the word for us so
you help bring along those who might not
know the word and that's a skill that I
think any of us who serve as teachers or
Educators could bring to help people
understand what we're saying I want to
ask you what are you thinking about next
what's the next term that you're
thinking of I put some thought into this
myself and maybe this is just where I am
in my age and my stage of life but I've
been thinking a lot of Fogo fear of
growing old and so relatedly Foo fear of
peeing often so I'm curious what's going
on for you in terms of your thoughts
about what's next to look at I love this
question because I had thought about
this but now you just got me to I'm
gonna I'm can I break some news here and
it's such the right place to do this
because of the Stanford connection so
I've been thinking about the Venture
Capital Market so I do Venture Capital
investing in addition to the other
things I do and right now there's a big
retrade happening you know down rounds
and renegotiations of terms and things
like that and it's a very interesting
phenomenon that needs a name and people
are starting to say oh it's pay to play
and all that sort of stuff and I don't
like that term I think it sounds very
negative because if you're a venture
capist and you're supporting a company
and you're able to renegotiate you know
all the crazy terms that you had last
year and get something a bit more
appropriate and support a company that's
a good thing and we should call that out
and we should appropriately value it I'm
calling that a support premium oh I like
it yes and I want to do something with
it support premium that's one of the
words that I really like and so I hope
all you VCS listening I want to be like
you know the person from Cowboy Ventures
who coined unicorn I want support
premium to be big all right well we'll
try to help you with that but I think
support premium spans Beyond just
venture capital I think like fomo and
phobo I think there are lots of areas of
our life where that idea
resonates well before I end i' like to
ask some questions of my guests that are
a little rapid fire give us a little
personal Insight are you up for
answering some of these yes my first
question is targeted based on who you
are and what you look at and study so I
want to ask you Patrick what gives you
fomo what gives you fomo the most for me
it's social it's all socially related I
always wonder am I missing out on some
great conversation or great connection
what gives you fomo oh what doesn't
everything I left the corporate world to
do something very unconventional and
I've loved every minute of it but I
constantly ask myself like is this the
right path for me and I think that
that's very natural in The Human
Experience and I try to shut it down and
I know how to manage it but I always
wonder should I have done this other
thing would I be better at this other
thing and I think you know the answer is
maybe yeah right right no and I can
relate to that too I've made several
career choices and and I often wonder
did I make the right choice I'm very
very thrilled with what I do but it's
always it's a curiosity of what could
the other be let me ask you question
number two who is a communicator that
you admire and
why so I just met this woman at a
conference in Sweden called Brilliant
Minds her name is rupe kuar Ku a r and
rupe is a poet she got up and read a
poem about the female experience it was
amazing and you all should check her out
she's got a huge stagram following and
just the fact that she in this day and
age that a
poet is doing is is it has the kind of
audience that she has and the things she
talks about aren't easy and when she
performs her poetry it is spellbinding
and then you hang out with her and she's
just like the nicest person and when I
met her I felt like I'd known her for
years she is able to connect with people
in a way that I find amazing whether
she's on a stage or in a small
conversation and I just came away being
like I really really admire her and I'm
glad that she's my
friend I'm not surprised that you pick
somebody who uses language in this case
poetry to be effective and that it's
somebody who's passionate in really
connecting and that seems to be who you
are too question number three our final
question what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication
recipe all right I love this question
the first is truth we got to be truthful
like misinformation disinformation it's
the worst truth is number one number two
humility when you're communicating who's
the star of the show it's not you it's
the person who receives the
communication whether you're a writer a
podcaster or just a person having a chat
and number three
panach got to have a little personal
style a little Charisma and so we have
this Rich language it's amazing use it I
absolutely agree and I think based on
what we've talked about today Patrick I
think it's not just objective truth
truth outside of us but also part of
what you talked about in terms of
managing fomo and phobo is we have to
think about our inner truth and what's
important to us making the other person
the star it's all about them absolutely
100% we hear that a lot on this podcast
and wholeheartedly believe it I want to
hear just a little bit more about panach
I love this idea besides the language we
use what else can convey this notion of
panache
it's a good question and by the way
everybody should have the experience of
having Matt summarize what you just said
because it's like it's great you you
summarize it I'm like did I it's here
better than what I said I'm very
impressed you're a good listener thank
you my wife would disagree by the way
but yes thank you for me panach sort of
like we spend so much
time trying to look good buying nice
clothes getting dressed up and all that
sort of stuff and then we open our
mouths and we should do the same we
should try to have a little bit of style
a little bit of Charisma a little bit of
Elegance language is it's an incredible
way to connect with people and if you
invest in language your ability to meet
people and make an impression on them
it's incredible and I found as I've
become a stronger Communicator I look at
every time I talk as an opportunity to
just experiment freestyle improvise and
just engage with people and the more
that you add a little flavor the better
you'll do it's like cooking a good
recipe a little extra flavor makes a big
difference just put turmeric in
everything it's going to be delicious
excellent I like it the point you made
there that I really took to heart is we
dress up ourselves for important
communication let's dress up our
language as well Patrick this has been
fantastic thank you for being here we
have all learned a lot about the way we
can approach our lives and perhaps
reduce some of the stress and pressure
we put on ourselves I certainly have I
wish you well with your books fear of
missing out as well as the 10%
entrepreneur and congratulations on the
success of fomos sapiens your podcast
thank you I want to thank you for
offering me a support premium and I wish
you the best of
luck thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Ryan Campos and me Matt
Abrahams our music was provided by Floyd
Wonder for more information and episodes
find us on YouTube or wherever you get
your podcasts thank you and please make
sure to subscribe and follow us on
LinkedIn